je pense qu'il ya deux choses c'est pas
pour rien qu'on a parlé d' omerta après
8 ou c'est à dire que la faire il ya eu
une éruption de la parole après laffaire
veinstein qui avait sept symptomatique
c'est effectivement personne n'avait
porté plainte et à la fois c'était un
secret de polichinelle c'est à dire que
tout le monde savait et beaucoup de gens
en témoigner a posteriori de la
déchéance on va dire de monsieur
einstein que oui tout le monde savait
qu'il était son comportement et ses le
sollicitude envers les femmes
c'est à dire qu'il y avait une omerta à
la base via parce que ces hommes étaient
trop puissants pour qu'on puisse même
tenté de porter plainte pour beaucoup
d'autres femmes
si elle parlait elle portait plainte est
le problème qui reconnut je pense
maintenant au plus haut niveau de l'état
c'est les classements sans suite c'est à
dire qu'on est dans un pays où on aime
quand on va porter plainte il ya 10% de
chances que le violeur soit condamné
c'est à dire que moi ce que j'ai fait
les plus dans mon association c'est de
l'accompagnement des victimes dans les
commissariats et les gendarmeries et je
peux vous assurer que la première chose
que je leur dis aux victimes c'est ça va
être classée sans suite il faut voir
comment on va penser l'après et enfin
nitoo a mis une une situation en france
qui a permis que les femmes puissent
parler enfin et c'est ce qui a fait
qu'on a eu l'impression qu'on remonter
loin dans l'histoire pour aller chercher
des dossiers d'une part que ce soit
valence
vanessa spring aura adèle haenel il a
fallu qu'elle même grandissent vanessa
string aura pourtant tout est écrit noir
sur blanc dans la littérature de made in
f
mais il a fallu qu'elle grandisse
qu'elle prenne la parole qu'elle écrive
un livre le 11 quand tu mens pour qu'on
voie ce qui crevait les yeux finalement
dans un situation
[Musique]